好 欢迎大家来到群艺期货 我是马克洋
今天我会讲上下半场
上半场我会分享一个稳赢不输的选择权策略
然后下半场会讲一个一天输200多万的我的交易实战复盘
那就是教大家怎么赢跟怎么输钱
今天我讲的会非常的尽量的让大家
就是完全没有做过交易的人也都可以听得懂
所以呢
虽然它是一个稳音不输的选择权策略
听起来非常厉害但是呢
相信就算没有做过交易的人听完也都是可以听得懂的
诶 这样的话
这样的话会比较好吗 还是
都可以
都可以吗
好 那我就继续用麦克风
好 那我们先讲
这个
稳音不输的选择权策略
那它是一个
跟台风架有关的策略
那今天我讲的两个主题
两个故事呢
都是我之前在我的FB粉砖上面有PO过的
那就是在台风架的公布的时候
你可以进行一些特殊的操作
然后呢这个几分钟之后就可以获利60万元
这是一个非常
低风险高报酬的操作
而且呢
这个策略有趣的是大部分的情况下
那选择权的PUT跟CODE它们
不会同时上涨
一定会是一个
等速的反方向
那除非是像这种超级特殊的情况
就是
PUT跟CODE
同时的
就是大幅的上涨
这大概会上涨的40%左右
在
短短的几分钟之内
好
那
这个我还是先
自我介绍一下
就是
给大家这个角色的刻板印象
这样的话
看影片的人
接下来会觉得这个影片更加有趣一点
我是马克洋
那
我以前是医生
然后
小时候有拿过一次考试的
世界冠军
就是澳零PER的
这个金牌
然后
后来有当过实况主
就是
打炉石的
然后我的专长是
从小就是数学家
然后后来呢
又有研究心理学
那今天
讲的下半场
才会比较跟心理学有关
上半场的策略
就纯粹的是
这个
教大家怎么玩这个数学游戏里面
一些非常有趣的情况
那
就是我在生涯玩过非常非常多的游戏
就是希望呢
今天这场讲座之后
不只是让大家学到一些什么赚钱的方法
那个都太俗气了
我希望今天大家可以
感受到数学的美妙
就是看完之后觉得说
就是
就是股市是一个猜数字的
的数学游戏嘛
那就是不只是赚钱
就是大家还要觉得说
这个游戏
其实真的是非常好玩
真的很想学数学
希望可以有
这样的效果
然后
大家不需要
不需要抄笔记啊
就是看到有人在那边抄我玩过什么游戏
这是不需要的
就是我每一次讲座之后呢
这些影片都会放上YouTube
然后呢
大家都可以免费的跟我拿PowerPoint
所以呢
如果你很想要让你的小孩玩一样的
这个游戏套组的话呢
你最后是可以
看那个
PowerPoint
然后一个一个下载
让你的小孩玩的
这个是非常不错
好
那
就是
因为我会
让希望就是
就算以前没有做过交易的人
看完这个
这个讲座呢
也都能够
听得懂
就是完全知道这个
策略是
在做什么
然后它的原理啊
推导的过程啊
这个
毕竟我以前是
数学家嘛
我还是比较注重这些
证明推导过程
希望大家
是真的
就是说
哦对这个
策略
然后你知道它的过程是怎样
然后觉得非常有道理
而不只是说
反正它那个就是
就是一个什么
数学世界冠军
他讲的肯定是这样
就我希望大家还是
相信
这个数学
不是相信人
这样
好
所以我就会从头开始讲
就是
我简略讲什么是选择权
那选择权呢
就是买方跟卖方
他们会对赌
那他们赌
就是赌
到特定一个时间
会不会涨或跌超过特定的数字
那你可以自己决定你要当
买方或者是卖方
那例如说你们可以赌
一个月之后
台积电会不会涨超过1200块
那
这个
可能你们可以讲好
就是
你可以自己决定要当庄家还是玩家
那玩家会付庄家
一点点钱
一笔钱
然后呢
如果有涨超过
你们约定的那个数字
台积电有涨超过1200块
那每涨超过1块
这个可能你就要付给他50块
那如果涨超过
100块的话
那就是
你要付他
50乘以100
那如果没有涨超过的话
当然这个
就是庄家通杀嘛
就是把那些钱就会
他走
就是归零回不来了
那在这个游戏里面
不是只有
这个
政府可以当庄家
大家都可以自己选择
你要当庄家
还是玩家
这个就是选择全这个游戏
所以呢
大家应该很容易可以想象就是
如果你要赌
在一个月之后
会不会涨超过1200块
还是你要赌
在
三年之后会不会涨到
1200块以上
那是不是
时间越久
就越有可能
那例如说
如果你是赌
一个礼拜之后
会不会涨超过1200块
那这个机率就
非常非常的接近零
对吧
除非
还一个大暴涨
不然的话是非常难发生这样的事情
所以呢
我们在这边就
知道一件事情
就是呢
如果是
那个
时间
就是
到期的时间
越长的话
那
这个选择权的价值应该会越高
因为
他越有可能
最后那个玩家可以拿到更多钱
那所以呢
玩家就应该
一开始就要付更多的钱
才能跟装家
买到这个选择权
对吧
好
那我们主要利用的就是
这样的一个想法
好
那
至于
这个
买方
跟卖方
他们之间一开始的权利金应该要付多少钱呢
这个是会有一个
这个数学模型来决定的
但是
大致上的概念应该大家可以
就是那个方向性的概念应该可以理解
就是
剩下的时间越多
那他就会越贵
然后还有再来就是
那个价钱如果离现在越远的话
那就会越便宜
因为他越不容易达到
好
那
就是
在这个游戏里面
一般来说
选择权卖方会赢
选择权买方
非常非常多的钱
那就是这是长期来说
所以
尽量在这个游戏里面呢
就是都不要去当玩家
永远都是去当装家
因为这是少数
你可以
负责当装家的机会
然后这个也一样是一个
装家会赢玩家钱的游戏
不过呢
在这个游戏里面
就是在这个策略里面
他是一个比较特别的
spot
就是
是一个玩家可以去赢
卖方钱的
就是买方可以赢
卖方钱的游戏
那因为我知道
很多小资组
他们就会
喜欢当选择权的买方
但是选择权买方
长期是会输很多钱
是非常不好的
所以就是尽量不要当选择权买方
只是
稍微提
提到一个这件事情
当然这也是这个策略有趣的地方
因为他是一个赚钱的买方策略
好
那
有一些东西会影响
那个选择权的时间价值
那我们在
就是
这边要讲的就是
距离到期日越长
时间价值越高
那当然
这个如果波动性越高的话
价值也会越高
比如说发生了战争
或者是
这个什么
飞弹射来社区
或者是有一些
两个国家之间发生冲突
或者是
就是有些事情是会让
这个市场波动性变高的
然后呢
这个无风险利益当然也会影响嘛
就是
如果你可以把钱
这个没有风险存到银行
那那个会影响
这个
世界上所有其他金融产品的价值
但是因为他几乎是固定的
所以我们就当做他不重要
然后这个策略的原理
就是
台股的周选择权
他的结算日是每个礼拜三
但是游戏规则是
如果
那个礼拜三
就是他
他如果
放假的话
那结算日就会变成下一天
变成礼拜四
那
台股的游戏规则是
依照台北市
有没有放假为准
就是如果什么台南
或其他任何的县市
都放假
但是只有
北北基没有放假的话
那
就是北北基有
有上班上课
就是
有上班的话
就是会开市
就算只有北北基放假的话
其实规则是台北市啦
但是现在北北基是
会同时的
那如果台北市放假的话
整个台股就会放假
好
那这个是
就是我先介绍一下这个游戏的游戏规则是怎样
所以呢
我们接下来
关注的就是
只有台北市
有没有放
放台风假
那如果
这个
周三跟周四都修饰的话
那就会顺眼两天
变成礼拜五才结算
那也就是说呢
你现在
礼拜二的晚上的时候
就可以关注
有没有放台风假
那如果呢
有放台风假的话
原本在礼拜三
会结算的
选择权
就会变成
礼拜四才结算
也就是说
剩下来的时间
是
大约一天
那就会变成是
大约两天
大家应该到这边
都还听得懂吧
就是现在是礼拜二的晚上
然后呢
大家在
晚上八点关注
会不会第二天放假
如果
没有放假的话
那就会是
一天之后结算
有放假的话
就会
突然变成两天之后结算
好
大家应该可以理解
这个公布
确定放台风假之后
时间
价值就会大增
而且马上反映在选择权的价格上
它是从一天变成两天
那是直接变两倍
是
大约两倍啦
就是突然多了
非常非常多的时间
当然晚上八点到
这个
就是一点半是
不到一天
不过呢
然后所以
而且日盘跟夜盘
它的波动率也有点不一样
不过那就是
一些
就是
好
其实没有很重要
反正就是一些数学的
的一些模型
但是呢
大致上你可以知道是
它的
距离结算的时间
是大幅的增加了
对吧
距离
时间大幅增加
那个选择权的价格
当然就是会大幅上涨
然后
好
然后再来就是台北市的
台风架公布的时间
它虽然是两点
但是它其实是非常不准时的
像今年
有两次是
在礼拜三放台风架
然后
第一次是凯米台风
然后结果呢
这个
就是讲完它的脸书在
15分钟之前
就不小心
这个贴出来说放台风架
然后
就
过了一下之后才赶快又把它删掉
然后过了
到8点的时候又再重po一次
但是
因为它
第一次po出来
那
就是放台风架
那所以
就是有时候它会
不小心提早公布
那像删破了那一次的话
就是晚了十几分钟才公布
所以呢
这个跟其他的
那些
就是
我是
这个
非常专精事件交易
像美国政府
每个月各式各样的经济数据公布
CPI、PPI
然后这个失业率
然后
制造业
ISM公布的那些
制造业P&I
非制造业P&I
它们都是
超级准时公布
就是它们政府已经有
设定好东西
然后所以
就是在
那个
就是例如说9点
半的00秒的时候
它就是会非常准时的公布出来
那所以
这个股市的波动就会非常的准
但是呢
这个台湾的公布台风架就没有设定的这么的严谨
所以
就是它有时候会早十几分钟晚
是差距超级无敌大的那种
看起来它们的小编应该是
用手手动
就是Key FB然后去发布
所以
有时候设定那个什么发布时间还会早十几分钟发布
那当然
就是
因为它们不知道这件事情
是会对股市有一个非常巨大的影响
就是
毕竟
政府官员它们应该是
就是
就是我们可以预设它们应该是不会去
学习选择权的数学模型之类的嘛
所以这是非常正常的事情
好
所以它们也没有
没有很在意这件事情
或许这个
它们
有人看了这个影片之后就发现
那确实是要整点设置
好
然后一般来说
Poot跟Core是不可能同时上涨
一定是等数的反方向
就是Poot涨了
0.3的话
那
这个Core也会
就是
跌0.3
这样
那
除非是像这种
超特别的情况
就是
因为
它的结算的时间
是突然大增嘛
所以Poot跟Core会同时变贵
好
那所以就是
这一次的话它是在
大概12分的
12分多的时候才
才
公布
那所以
这一次是我第一次操作这个策略
所以就是
这一次
今年虽然有两次
这个礼拜三的台风
但是我到第二次
礼拜三的
就是
礼拜三放台风架的台风的时候
我才
第一次操作这个策略
然后所以执行的还
不是很好
那在之后呢
这个
我或者是
在场大家
执行这个策略都可以执行的更好
因为
就是第一次操作
我其实不是很确定
它是不是真的
在线世界是会成功的
所以呢
我就是按的很慢这样
就是
前面就是3啊5啊
这样慢慢按
然后看到
这个价格真的是一直
增加
然后所以
就是才
才慢慢的按上去
然后你看从这边
12分15秒按到这边
13分多我才
就是按了一点点
然后价格就
真的涨上去
从
从120
就是上面
就喷到上面
就已经到
140了嘛
就是
马上就增加了很多
那
就是试驾
试驾持
当时的
但是
因为我不是很
确定这样一定会成功
那如果
这样来看的话
就是
如果
我
已经有操作过这个车员
然后很确定它会成功的话
那
我就是可以
一次开很多的
下单夹
然后
比如说
120到140之间
能够尽量买
就是尽量
120到140之间全部都买完
因为我已经知道
它会上涨
40%左右
那
至少你在涨
20%之内
你把它全部
尽量
能按你的额度
能按多少就按
会是非常不错的
就是
好
但是因为
我第一次做
还没有很确定
它会成功
然后这个也是蛮有趣的事情
反正就是
我大概会是
每
三个月左右
在群艺讲一次讲座
然后就会讲
最近
做的新的交易的实战付款
然后我自己这个人
我的
策略词组合也都是
会一直
持续的更新跟进步
反正这个是
好像是10月吧
是吗
上面好像有写
好 忘记了
诶 下面这张是不是就有日期
10月
10月多发生的事情
好 那反正就是
我策略词会持续的更新
那如果有什么
有趣的东西的话
这个有机会
也可以跟大家分享
好
那
然后
就是
那它简单来说
它操作的方式就是
你就在那边刷新
讲万安的脸书
然后
就是
尽量是在8点之前就开始刷
因为
它有时候
有一次是提早15分钟就不小心公布了
那
就是你就
早一点点然后在那边重新整理
看它的脸书什么时候更新
说有放台风架
那它公布放台风架之后呢
你就去
双买选择权
那
因为
买台子选择权的原因是因为
这个是有叶盘而且流动性很高的嘛
那
这个策略当然也可以
就是它也不是只有在台股试用嘛
如果其他的商品
在其他国家会有这种
任何一个
突发的事件让
结算日改变的情况的话
都一样可以使用这样的策略
那这个也是
这个玩游戏很重要
就是你在各种不同的
的这个游战术里面
就是它的那个战术的蕴含应该是
很容易可以在套用在其他游戏里面使用的
然后那这个策略有吻应不输吗
就是
当然还是可以抬杠说
这个可能蒋旺安
他发布放台风架
其实没有放台风架
那这个并没有违反这个
物理的定理嘛
那
但是就是
不太容易发生嘛
毕竟
这个
每多放一次台风架
在科学统计上那个选票
在下一次的选举的选票是会增加的
也就是说
就是他们如果可以放台风架的话
如果以选票作为考验的话
他们是会尽量放台风架的
那所以
几乎不可能有说他宣布放台风架之后
然后最后不放台风架
那那个
应该直接被喷烂
下次选票
可能直接扣2%扣3%
那实在是太亏了
他们不太会做这样的事
那另外一个可能失败就是
整个造势商突然不造势
那个流动性很差
那所以这个策略呢
如果你是在
其他的市场做其他的商品的话
你也需要考虑他的流动性
就是如果
那个商品他的流动性很低的话
那就没有办法做这个策略了
因为
就是选择权
他的价值虽然应该要上涨多少
但是呢
他可能没有上涨
因为
那个造势商可能根本就不造势
那就是
其实我们在各种
交易各种商品的时候都有可能遇到这样的事情
例如说台股在交易全证的时候
那可能那个造势商根本就不想造势
那流动性就会非常非常的差
这样子
好所以这也是尽量就是完全不要交易全证的原因
好
那这样的交易机会常见吗
就是
台风价刚好放在礼拜三的话
在今年的话是有发生两次的
但是
他也是不一定会发生嘛
就是
毕竟台风价不一定会放在礼拜几
然后甚至有时候
可能就是刚好那一年都没有放台风价
所以
这个策略在什么时候会再发生呢
也不一定
但是
大致上来说
他
他会是一个
反正你学会了他
他在你的生涯当中
可能总是会发生很多次的
这个是我第一次执行
那或许在下一次执行的时候
可能就是
可以
一次可以赚个两三百万
或者是
如果当时的部位跟大家可能赚超过一千万
都是非常有可能的
那这是就是
而且他是非常非常的低风险高报酬的一个策略
好
那
这个
你在
8点的时候在那边刷新脸书
然后结果
讲完公布没有放台风价的话
那怎么办
这时候要怎么交易呢
大家有什么想法吗
好
没错就是
那就不要进场就好了
那就是很可惜
没有放台风价
这是
就是
我讲这策略的时候
不知道为什么很多人都会问这个问题
没有放假你就赚不到钱
那这个是非常简单的事情
对吧
就是
这个策略当然不是
每天都会发生的嘛
不是每天都放台风价
对吧
好
那再来就是为什么过后印呢
那这个
这个也是一个大家很喜欢台杠的问题
大家说这个一定赢的策略为什么不后印呢
那其实呢
虽然他
问的人大部分是台杠
但是呢
其实他还是有蕴含了一个
很不错的问题
就是如何决定交易当中的下注尺度
那后印也是一种下注尺度嘛
你只下一点点也是一种下注尺度
好所以下半场我就会讲如何
决定交易中的下注尺度
那在这一次的话当然就是因为这是我第一次爱
那我还不是很确定这个策略
它的可行性
就是但是
在我以后知道它
是非常可行的之后
那我就可以用更好的方法一次
就是吃下更大的部位单
那可能就不会是只有赚几十万
好
那再来就是
就是当然
在具体的执行上可能还可以做一些调整和优化
例如说你要
开哪些的下单夹要选的是架平还是架内
的尽量的持单啊
然后
你要stradle还是strangle啊
还有你在持单的过程你要看哪些的数据去
调单停利或者是重新建仓
好好像有点正回馈
好没关系
这个
我应该是非常大声的
所以我用讲话的应该也是没有关系
好
那
就是
我
就是我
我大概目前应该是十几个策略吧
我也不确定是几个
然后呢我每个策略都有
录成一个可能一个半小时到两个半小时的
教学影片
那
这个
就是影片可能会讲的更详细一点的一些
比较无聊的就是
一些
一些微调
但是呢如果你是本来就会做交易的人的话呢
其实你也不需要那些
就是
你光是听了上面这些
你基本上就已经完全可以执行这个策略
就是
在前一天的晚上八点的时候把下单夹开好然后看有没有放台风架
有的话
就是直接暴力的双买
那这个
就可以赚很多钱了
那
出厂的话当然有很多不同的方式嘛
可以听力啊
调单啊
或是出调再重新建仓
好那个
正回馈其实不是麦克风的问题啊
就是我
播出来的声音又被这个收回去了
然后它就会一直
变成一个放大正向循环
好
就是如果有发生的时候呢
我就把它关掉一下
再打开
就可以打破这个正回馈的回圈
顺便有让大家学到一点物理
真是不错
好
那
刚刚讲说
就是有各种不同的停力跟出厂方式嘛
但是呢
就是
其实最简单的就是你就是进厂之后
然后它大概就会上涨
这个到根号二倍嘛
就是
40%左右
那所以呢
就是你可以在
涨个30% 35%的时候把它出掉
那这样也是非常不错的
好
那
就是
选择选它剩下的那个时间价值
大概你可以把它近四层
是
就是
就是剩下的时间
开根号会跟价格成正比
那是
因为
就是在那个模型里面
它当然还有另外一个项
然后它的那个项它的
这个
就是它是一个什么
Long
什么履约价除以现货价格
讲错了
是现货价格分支
履约价格
那但是
就是
履约价格通常跟现在现货价格会蛮接近的嘛
例如说
现在股市如果是
2万2000点
那你可能就算挂在
200点之外
或是
400点之外
400点之外就已经算是非常非常远的价外了
那但是400点占整个2万2000点的
这个比例也是
超级低嘛
那所以
就是
履约价格
履约价格分支现货价格会非常非常接近1
然后它
再被取一个
对数就是取一个自然对数之后它就会
很接近0
那所以那个项就会
基本上被忽略好反正基本上就是
你可以当作
大部分的情况下
全折全的
这个
价值
价格会正比于剩下的时间的
开更好倍
这样子
那所以
大概
一天变两天大约会变成
就是
更好大概是1.41
大约会上涨40%
那当然
就是
有放台风价这件事情
它
并不是其他因素没有改变嘛
就是还是有一些其他因素的改变但是
就都是一些
微乎其微的
就是可以忽略的事情
大致上就是上涨
更好而倍
到更好而倍
这样子
好
好那这个就是
这个我第1个要讲的
上半场
好
就是呢
就是它虽然
就是看起来是蕴含了很多的数学
就是好像很复杂但是这些策略
它的下单执行都非常的简单就是
你就是开好那个选择权的那个下单甲嘛
然后看到有公布就直接
试驾双满
是非常非常简单
那困难的应该都是
这个
这个策略背后蕴含的
数学还有
就是对游戏规则啊你要怎么
在看到各式各样的游戏规则之后呢去
去发现一些
这个可能可以攻击的游戏漏洞或者是
就是一些数学策略
好那但是呢因为
就是
我会想好策略那可能我已经想了很多很多
十几个策略了那所以
大家只要学到这些策略应该都是非常容易
复制跟执行的
好应该大部分人都听得懂这个策略对吧
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive